[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here welcome
back to dope tech the series where we
take a look at the most impressive most
amazing most incredible tech that's out
there brought to you by the dope tech
shirt of course and so in this
quarantine edition of dope tech we've
got some tech that's around the studio
right now
that is still really crazy impressive
sometimes we do like a montage version
sometimes the whole episode is about one
thing there's some stuff around the
studio to show let's get into it okay
item number one is this
table
that i've been talking about on twitter
and instagram and showing so this is
called the sisyphus table
sisyphus table there's a bunch of
different styles and and types and
versions of this but what we should know
is sisyphus is the figure from greek
mythology who is condemned to rolling a
huge boulder up a mountain for eternity
on this table that boulder is this steel
marble rolling through the sand
and sisyphus is a rotating magnet
positioned by a wi-fi connected robot
arm i've been super into this table for
no other reason than just how cool it
looks
when it's doing its thing and how i
guess easily distracted i can be
by a little marble rolling
around but it's really cool
fundamentally it's just a regular table
on top with this thin layer of silica
sand that comes with the table itself
you literally just pour it in and spread
it out and set it up then underneath is
the tech itself which is a computer
that's rotating this arm around with a
magnet on it that controls where that
ball goes and it's a pretty fine-tuned
control as you can see to the point
where you know these overlapping lines
can create these thin lines and really
precise shapes and designs you can add
more or less sand too for a different
look
and there's an led ring around the table
that makes this dramatic evenly lit look
that i'm super into then on top of all
that there's an app there's a sisyphus
app that lets you control everything so
there are whole playlists of
user-generated patterns and images that
you can have it draw some are simple
and some are much more complex and you
can even attempt to make your own in the
app itself but it is super hard let me
tell you to make anything that looks as
good as the stuff that's already there
so i stick with the pre-made ones it
also does this really satisfying erasing
sequence after every new piece of art i
could watch it all day literally which
is i guess why i put it in a different
room but really that's what made it dope
tech for me it's it's technically
internet connected it has an app it is
tech but really it's moving art it's
it's mesmerizing watching the ball go
around in circles and draw these new
designs erase everything then draw
something new erase it again and just
continue perpetually
forever
just like the myth itself all right next
item up is this guy right here this is
the matte black
phantom reactor it's a wireless speaker
it's pretty compact you can see it's
plugged into the wall
and it's most impressive for how small
it is
versus
how incredibly loud it actually gets so
this version of the phantom is it's
maybe the size of an ipad mini it's like
eight inches long six inches wide
and it weighs 4.3 kilograms or about 10
pounds so it's like a bowling ball so
it's a super compact design
and it's also pretty simple so besides
being matte black it's nice and clean
it's the smaller full range driver on
the front and then these two side pieces
are the woofers that really move air and
then on the back you have these fins
that are literally a heat sink and the
whole idea is the cabinet is so compact
and so dense that it produces this super
loud sound from how much air it moves
and it moves a lot of air when it's
playing you know at high volumes you get
this massive
punchy rich bass from these big drivers
and how much air they they push from all
that small cabinet space it's already
connected to spotify let me play a
little quick demo from jordan edmonds
it's half volume
[Music]
so i got two of them but when you get
two of the exact same model you can pair
them together as a stereo pair so
there's one over here one on the other
side of the studio and they're a
left-right stereo pair and then when you
connect to it in spotify it sees it as
one speaker and appropriately splits it
and then you get that sweet loud stereo
image it actually does have a little bit
of computer on the inside for the record
every speaker does but this one of
course has internet connected features
too so it has an arm processor and half
a gig of ram and you know your wi-fi
chip that's all it needs and yeah this
speaker is a it's a tiny portable noise
complaint is what it is it gets so crazy
loud at high volume uh and has
surprisingly little distortion at those
high volumes not surprisingly it is a
pretty bass heavy sound overall there
isn't really a midsize driver to focus
on the mids so it can kind of feel like
a v-shaped eq but honestly for what i'm
using it for filling up a room somewhere
or just outdoor space it's not a huge
deal and i know in the title it says
it's a 3500 speaker there's actually a
couple different versions of it there's
a 600 and a 900 watt version this is the
the 900 watt compact version but then
there's a bigger
phantom
that's 2 000 watts
and then 4 500 watts so you're over 100
decibels peak at that point which is
nuts but that high-end version costs
about four thousand dollars so you know
this is uh a little safer than that i
guess all i'm really saying is
it's worth the noise complaint it's
really impressive okay this next one in
dope tech is for my fellow video nerds
out there you'll know who you are if i
say helios 44-2
and your ears perk up a little bit
that's where we're going with this one
so in order to understand why this
is dope tech you have to understand
what's so special about
the original helios 44-2 so this is my
helios 44-2 lens it obviously doesn't
look quite like the rest of the lenses
in the collection and that's because
it's a vintage used russian lens you can
grab on amazon or ebay for about 60
bucks i've had it for a while and it's
known for its swirly bokeh and really
fun optical characteristics see most
modern lenses especially in the cinema
world are very clinical rectilinear
super high on maximizing sharpness
minimizing distortion and giving you the
most accurate look possible and
generally that's good but sometimes you
just want a more fun look to play with
so you might have recognized this swirly
background in various mkbhd videos in
the past and these have all come from
this one little vintage helios lens it
is a 58 millimeter lens and it's not
particularly sharp and it's also so old
that it's really not very well built or
easy to use but it gets the job done and
the look is fun so this as you might
have guessed is what's called a rehoused
lens a rehouse version of this and it's
it's pretty common in the industry to
rehouse various lenses for certain
reasons
uh but for this one it makes perfect
sense so it's still as optically fun and
unique as the helios because it's the
same glass but it's in a barrel that
gives a much better build quality a much
longer life
and then a much longer focus throw to
make it easier to focus on things it
gives it gears for a follow focus if you
want to use that it gives it threads for
filters if you want to add those and
just overall a more satisfying confident
feel
this one's made by a company called iron
glass it's linked below and it's awesome
so to those wondering where the swirly
background shots come from now you know
fun fact did you know
that
one terabyte sd cards
are just out there in the world now
along with one terabyte micro sd cards
as well
this
is 350 bucks so it is pretty expensive
for an sd card but it's also not insane
for a terabyte and the grand scheme of
terabytes you can buy
anyway i'd feel a little nervous putting
that much data on a card you could just
snap in half but i'll link this below
along with all the rest of the stuff
from this episode in case you're uh
feeling dangerous but anyway there you
have it an insane bluetooth speaker a
magnetic table
vintage rehouse lenses another episode
of dope tech in the books thank you for
watching and i'll catch you guys in the
next one
peace